[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad well here we are with
another episode and another absolute lad
10 years ago today's guest started his
professional rugby career as a 18 year
old playing for auckland and not long
after he was playing for the blues he
then headed over to france to play for
bordeaux and then off to scotland to
play for edinburgh he's since returned
home where he's had a stint with the
mighty hurricanes and now he's down in
christchurch with the mighty crusaders
he's had some career for a 28 year old
and anyone who has spent just a minute
with us lad will know he is one of the
greatest lads around it is the great
simon hickey welcome mate
thanks mate have an intro there are mum
would i would be proud listening to that
one uh thanks mate yeah it's been a uh
been a interesting journey to get to
this point when you sound out all the
teams like that you know i've sort of
certainly hopped around a few places but
as you said it has been a an enjoyable
journey so
yeah good to be on the show mate thanks
very much for having me no no problem
mate like i said crazy career like so
many teams and you've seen a lot and
you're still so young so make looking
forward to hearing a little bit more
about it but how you're finding
christchurch how's the crusaders
it's good eh um
yeah
coming down here i guess you're i was
wondering you know what what makes me
tick you know why are they such a such a
strong team year after year and um you
know i think
having a few months in the environment
you can sort of see why um you know
they're just the ultimate professionals
they love their code
um you know and
they work work hard and work smart and
yeah it's a really really cool team to
be a part of how does it compare to the
other teams that you've been involved in
i know you've been with the blues being
with the hurricanes you've seen all
these different environments around the
world what makes the crusaders so damn
good
um yeah it's hard question to answer
that one um
but i think
i said it just before like they love
their code they um you know the boys
they really do love it and you know they
do the extra work um required you know
that other places that that might get
skimmed over you know boys you'll come
in at four o'clock on a
friday afternoon and you know there's a
good chance that there's three boys
sitting on a computer going over making
sure they know their roles and just
little stuff like that um you know
they're over professional and um don't
leave any stone unturned going into a
game
is there any bet been anyone down there
who's really impressed you really stood
out with how they go about their
business
um
oh there's quite a few that's a tricky
question but you get look at someone
like ethan blackadder um you know he's
an absolute grafter i know he's a he's a
lad who's been on here before listen to
his episode um you know so so guys like
him um who work hard um dave
uh you know there's all sorts of boys um
you know they they do the do the work
required and um you know just what else
makes the crusaders so good i think it
probably helps that they have some
exceptional rugby players in the squad
too i like you turn up to training and
you're pretty much training with the all
blacks it's it's pretty cool yeah and
have you found it personally obviously
you've got a battle with richie milwanga
to try and get a
starting spot at the ten jersey um have
you found that
yeah look it's been um it's been all
good mate it was obviously it was nice
that at the start of the season you know
rich had a wee bit of a sabbatical so
ferg and i got a bit of a crack at it um
and that was good just to get some footy
like for me personally i hadn't played
in like 15 months prior to that because
injury um so it was great to get some
footy um i mean i i came down here
knowing that richie's
you know the number one ten and you know
that that ain't gonna change he deserves
that spot but you know i've just got to
work hard and funny things happen in
rugby so i'm just doing my best to make
sure that um you know i'm i'm prepared
to play and hopefully
um opportunities pop up as the season
progresses for me to get some more
chances on the field
so do you see it as a real battle
between you and ferg to get that back up
spot get that bench spot and then if
richie does go down one of you two other
guys i'm given the opportunity
yeah i think so i mean that's what i
came down sort of uh sort of thinking it
was you know battling it out for for
that spot um as well as just learning
and um you know trying to
reignite my love for the game um you
know spent last year injured and to be
honest i didn't have a huge amount of
clubs coming calling after me i hadn't
hadn't played much
much footy in a while and coming off an
acl injury so i was just stoked when the
crusaders gave me the opportunity and um
you know to be here it's great to learn
and no doubt get better at my game and
hopefully get some opportunities but i
think the year here will you know will
do a lot of good for me as well and how
is the knee feeling
yeah it's good
it's good a um
first long-term injury so i had no idea
what it would be like but i certainly
when i'm on the field like i feel like
it doesn't inhere my game at all um
yeah so it's good to go
and how tough was that to deal with what
you said first long-term injury
what was it 12 months
tough thing to come back from how did
you find it
yeah it was shitty um
well i i got my head around it but just
the timing i really sucked like i'd come
back from overseas um you know a long
time overseas really excited to play
super rugby stoked the hurricane to give
me a chance to play um
and then we had an internal hit out you
know in pre-season sort of last one
before the proper game started and um i
just dang that uh making a tackle um so
it was just a dagger timing like i you
know i was really excited to try and
push my case and play super rugby again
and get some good opportunities and then
bang that happened so it took me a while
to get my head around it but um
yeah i mean i i sort of chipped away at
the rehab process it was interesting
hearing to so i think tom robinson and
um ethan blackout are talking about
like loving that process and
just making the most of it and
you know i probably wasn't too far
different
um you know i just i don't mind routine
so i just got into a routine worked hard
and then you know you kind of get a bit
of a mental out from footy so
um
the injury sucks time rings timing
sucked but um you know using the year to
just get away from footy was also quite
nice
and you also got into a little bit of
coaching coaching the hurricane 20s
during that time so i know you and jamie
both had a huge influence on their
hurricanes 20 side along with lardy i'm
sinking a few steinies no doubt
yeah that was um that was good fun uh me
and beautifully the long-term injured
boys got tossed in the deep end to go
down and coach from taupo
but hell it was fun and i got an insight
into coaching and it's thirsty work
yeah so do you think coaching's a career
path for you because you've always been
a very
smart thinker of the game got a great
rugby mind
i don't know i um
i've never had a massive desire to coach
but um
you know that might change and as i get
older that that may change like my
brother jono he's he's into his coaching
and i think he's got a real good mind
for it um
yeah it might change for me but i think
um
i hope i've got a few more years playing
left to me and then i'll just wait and
see the one thing that would be good
about about coaching is um
just being in and around the rugby
environment again you know it's hard to
replicate that elsewhere um and it's
pretty cool so
potentially coaching but it's certainly
um you know up and yeah
happy to do something else as well
exciting times but you mentioned jono
there i i am keen to hear about um your
upbringing both of you too guys i know
you're both absolutely glad so um what
was your what was your childhood like
utah growing up
that was good eh um yeah we had
we had a good um good childhood mum and
dad looked after us very well um
yeah so jono's three years older than me
um and pretty much my whole childhood i
was just trying to keep up with them so
um lots of sport you know we'd be
packing our bags jumping on our bikes
and riding up to the uh
to the footy ground and just kicking
goals for three hours on a sunday
afternoon or
in the summer we'd be doing the same
sort of thing going to the cricket nets
so um just heaps of sports not many toys
not much lego but uh yeah just heaps of
sports and yeah it was good fun and was
it always a 50 50 split between cricket
and rugby
yeah pretty much growing up yeah summer
was crooked once it was rugby and um you
know neither was the favorite uh i know
christmas was always dominated by like
backyard cricket and stuff like that and
um yeah love my cricket and then
obviously jono went down
uh he went down a cricket path for his
first few years out of school um
i i stopped playing after school but um
yeah it was yeah love them both
so what caused you to stop playing
qriket was it
by all accounts you weren't too great at
getting out your teammates all used to
hide when you get out so
you're a bit of a psycho after you'd
been dismissed
yeah i was a bit of a psycho my whole
childhood to be
honest when i say keeping up with john
it was he'd just
hate me you know whether it be rugby or
crooked he'd just bait me bait me bait
me and he'd know that he'd just hit him
and i'd lose my [ __ ] so i um
yeah there's a few occasions i'll be
chasing around the backyard with a
cricket bed or whatever
um
but unfortunately that wasn't only the
backyard i was never very good at
getting out playing like first 11 stuff
the boys and
i'll get out and i'd come off the field
just fuming and the boys almost huddle
outside the changing room just giggling
just waiting to hear the reactions so
i i i think i nearly learnt to control
it by the end of my uh time at
school yeah it was certainly a work on
for a while there is that why you quit
did you run out of bats
ah the bet was the one thing i didn't
throw it was too expensive so i walk and
place the bat and then everything else
was a free-for-all
gloves were great to throw
oh so you were smart around it so oh i
love it yeah
yeah
were you i destroyed mom
yeah i was better yeah yeah
never got into the bowling
oh like i could bowl some
um
some like right arm darts but there
wasn't much spin on the ball
um yes i was more of a better growing up
and what about your rugby were you
always a 10
yeah pretty much 10 or a 9 um
i played like a season of nine
um at school one year
but now pretty much 10 and it stayed
that way really like a lot of tens
could cover 15 whereas i um for me i may
not happily jump out the back but my
profile probably splits more to slide
into nine um but you just don't really
see that these days yeah true so when
did you think rugby was gonna be the
option for you um
yeah i guess it's segment form like i
played cricket and rugby right up
through and i love my cricket but um
i guess there wasn't a clear sort of
pathway with cricket um like you sort of
jump into
pretty jumped into like a auckland
academy sort of set up but
um i think the reason i chose footy is
just because i i
loved it a bit more i quite like
you know the camaraderie that comes with
footy you know you really work hard for
80 minutes and
um you know and then it's done and you
can enjoy your weekend so that probably
played into it but
um yeah i got the opportunity to join
the auckland academy and they offered to
pay me like
five thousand dollars a year and i just
thought that was the jackpot so
yeah
yeah and that was sort of how i made my
decision not on five grand but just a
little bit more love for rugby to
cricket
the five grand help
and i'd imagine those free weekends
would have played a big part too because
you've always been one who has enjoyed
your weekends
yeah yeah that's other thing
certainly enjoyed my first year on
school uh
yeah nah but i do like i do love footy
for that i love um you know working hard
with your mates for 80 minutes and then
you know post game being able to park up
and have a few beers and just enjoy it
so going back to your school why did you
go to um kings because your brother went
to st kent is that right yeah so um john
i went to saint kent he got a
cricket scholarship out there um
and then i was pretty keen to go to st
kent as well applied for a scholarship
but didn't get one
but managed to get one out to kings so i
ended up going there um
yeah it was brilliant though i really
loved my time at ken's awesome school
and you were the first 15 captain first
11 captain
you were an absolute wizard at schoolboy
level
no i wasn't first within captain that
was fussy full time but i think i got
the i think i got the job for like one
or two games once he um he got injured
but
um
yeah no it was it was good i had a had a
good run at school like the sports at
king's was awesome and the support um
yeah it was great
and then how did you feel when you came
out of school you're into the club footy
is this when you linked up with jono
again playing um club rugby um yes i
went to grandma carlton out of school
that was like
um
my family club pretty much so i think
dad would have disowned me if i went
anywhere else
um at this stage jonah was still playing
jonah was still playing cricket but um
yeah i went to grandma carlton um
managed to make the premier side first
year out like the top tier side
um and we had an awesome euro that was
one of my finest years of rugby it was
um we had a stacked team we managed to
win the competition but throughout the
whole season it was just
work hard play hard pretty much um yeah
had some great saturday nights at the
club what did that look like
ah you know you know what it's like um
had some had some great quarters being
the young guy
the boys generally make me do whatever
and i was one of those guys who's just
yep sweet whatever you want
i was always up for it so
it was um
yeah it was a good year it was a lot of
fun
and did you think your form was good
enough to get called into the auckland
squad
um
i was in the academy auckland academy so
but i never
expected to play for auckland that year
um
there gareth and skim and then uh
another guy signed
so i didn't expect to to play i was just
focused on having a good season of club
footy um played well and then
sort of found out that i was in the mix
um
you know
once the season came close so i never
expected to play for auckland that year
but um it worked out that i was in the
23 um for most the games that season i
wrote the point for 80 quite a lot
behind
chicken but
uh it was epic being involved that first
year out of school it was yeah brilliant
and did you feel comfortable
um
oh
somewhat as you know it was
i felt like i was good enough to be
there um
but at the same time it's pretty
nerve-wracking you know trying to lead
those older guys around as a team as a
young team trying to lead them around um
so
parts of that run were a little bit um
you know new to me but i love love the
experience so and did you ever feel like
your size was ever going to be a barrier
like you you're only 81 kgs now you're
probably even smaller back then
um did you ever feel like that was gonna
be something that would hold you back or
were you always confident that you were
big enough and good enough
um oh i never really felt like it would
hold me back um
yeah it was interesting sort of when you
came out of school i feel this was about
10 years ago a lot of the
um
snc was around you know you just got to
get bigger bigger bigger um
you know and i
sort of got to around 82 kgs or
something and then
that was about it for me um and i never
really felt like it was going to hold me
back i mean i've always been quite brave
defensively so i felt like
you know whilst i'm probably not going
to win
any uh huge amount of collisions on with
my tackles i'll certainly you know be
brave enough to put my head in spokes
and try and chop guys down so i never
felt like it was going to be an issue
you know some coaches probably thought
you know they wanted someone a bit
bigger but um
for me i i didn't see it as a big deal
and i still don't
and then you were picked into the new
zealand 20 squad a and
the squad that you were starting ahead
of richie monger and some other big
names there um did you feel any pressure
around being in that role
um
yeah so i was lucky enough to play two
years of 20s so my first year we were
over in france
um and i was sort of coming back from
injury but played a few games and we
lost them
uh
lost in a semi and then the next year um
yeah played on that team with like
richie and damo and anton leonard brown
and just some superstars eh
jaco was on that team as well jackson so
like we had some yeah real superstars in
that team but um
it was funny because i was like looking
back on it now i was captain of that
team because i'd had a wee bit of super
rugby exposure
um and i was yeah i was
confident in that role and stuff but i
got injured like two games into the comp
or something
so i was out and then i think richie
went to 10 and damien went to 15 so not
a bad ah yeah not a bad little
background
probably worked out the best for them
no that's something that stood out
throughout your careers like you're
you've been captain and pretty much all
the sides you've been involved in i
remember you even captaining auckland at
a really young age so what is it about
that you that makes you such a good
captain material
i don't know to be honest mate um
like i try to be a good team man and
hard worker and um
yeah try and let my actions do talking
more than anything but probably just
um you know in those years where i was
captain for auckland initially we had
quite a few guys called up to all blacks
so you know you lose a bit of experience
and then it you know fell down the
pecking order but um yeah i loved being
captain for wakanda i was very very
proud to do that and um
yeah yeah it was cool cool
how old were you then because i think i
remember playing against you i was at
taranaki and you were at auckland and we
were both captains of the size but you
must have been about
20 were yeah
yeah well i went overseas when i was
21 so i think yeah about um
about 20.
yeah so pretty yeah pretty young pretty
young looking back on it but i um
probably didn't think about it that much
at the time we had we had a coach paul
feeney who was um he's a good man paul
and uh yeah he just filled me with
confidence hey as you saw just be
yourself and
so i did and yeah it was sweet
and so you were playing what age were
you playing for the blues must have been
even earlier than that
no i think i had they booed for the
blues at 20. um
yeah i think i just turned just turned
20 and debuted
i remember that day i was we were
actually playing against crusaders
and i
got told on a monday i was playing
and
it was from
kerwin and he was like oh yeah yeah
you're playing this week and i'll say i
am sweet so but on the bench or and he's
like
no you're starting unless you don't want
to i was oh [ __ ]
so because that whole um the whole uh
preseason for the blues they had me
playing at nine
because that was the year where they had
um like benji was there
so they had bng and then chris knox and
baden kerr so
you know in my head i was down the
picking order in terms of teams
so most of preseason they had me running
at nine
just as like a 910 cover and then
[Music]
and then
we lost to the highlanders round one and
um
okay everyone calls me into his office
and he's like yeah you're playing i was
like oh [ __ ] i haven't played any 10 at
all
but uh it was yeah no it was pretty
exciting and then i remember running out
onto the field it was our kickoff and um
it was richie mccor standing on the tent
you know where the number seven used to
stand like right in front and i was just
like what am i doing here
but uh
yeah no i got into the game and and
loved and actually went right that day
but yeah it was pretty cool pretty cool
to play for the blues at that age
100 and one person you mentioned there
was uh benji marshall what was it like
having him involved in that squad
it was cool he was um
benji was an awesome dude like awesome
team man um it obviously didn't really
work out for him
um rugby was here for for whatever
reason but um it was cool epic to like
get to know someone that um you know
i've always loved my rugby league and
stuff so you know you watch all the
benji highlight videos and whatnot and
so to get to know them and and play with
them it was pretty cool
what sort of stopped them from kicking
on and rugby union do you think
it's a hard question that eh but um
i think
i think they brought him over sort of
hoping he'd be 10
but you know rugby is such a different
game to
league you know there's a lot more
decision well you know like the game
management for a tenant league is so
much different to a half and
in the nrl
um and so
it wasn't really a 10 and then the blues
had charles pierce at fullback who was
like our best player so it just kind of
worked out that there wasn't overly a a
spot for him so that probably didn't
help i mean i don't know exactly and i'm
not the right person so it's a comment
but that in my opinion it was probably
just part of the problem here so did you
get a heap of game time that year
yeah i did yeah i got like i think i
played 10 games that year
so i played that game against crusaders
and then yeah i got i got a lot of
starts that season um
and i went not too bad that sort of had
ups and downs and
um yeah had a few good games we sort of
probably won
i think we won all our home games and
lost all our away games which was pretty
classic blues at that time
um
uh yes i want to write but to be honest
i probably just wasn't quite ready to
you know to be a
starting team at super rugby level at
that age
yeah well mate you were so young and
everything seemed to happen so quickly
for you eh
yeah it's a it did so like i mean i
wouldn't take any of it back but um
like it's it's shaped you know the
career i've had which has been great so
far and
whatnot but um yeah if i had my time
again you know easing things
eating myself into it you know might be
might have been a better way to just
slowly build um whereas what ended up
happening as i got um you know thrown
thrown in there um played alright had
some average games and then sort of got
tossed out the other side pretty quickly
yeah so that's one thing i've always
wondered about your career is why you
said you left
for france at only 21 years old such a
such a shame to be going over so early
so what what was the thought process
behind that or was there literally
nothing to hear for you
yeah so um
i had i had that first season with the
blues where i played played a fair bit
um
and then uh i got injured missed the end
of the season and the next season i was
with the blues again
but to be honest they weren't really
interested in playing me like i was on
the bench quite a lot
but they weren't that interested in
putting me on the field
um you know so that that wasn't great
then there was change of coaches
um following that and they were sort of
humming and hiring oh there might be a
spot might not be
um you know so there's quite a lot of
that around new zealand um you know
there might be a spot for you here maybe
not and then
um yeah my agent was just like oh you've
got interest from a club called bordeaux
in france i've never heard of him um
but uh
he was like look it's a good place
what do you reckon and it was just for
eight months so it was like go do that
sort of during super
and then come home for
um the auckland season
so i was like yeah why not pull trigger
on it and that was kind of yeah why i
went over there
and then you didn't come back did you
stayed there for three years wasn't it
yeah so i went for the eight months and
then i came back to play for auckland
but before i came back um i think you
know i'd have been going quite well over
there
and so i resigned for two more seasons
but came back and played for auckland um
in between true so how did you find it
you obviously loved it over in france
yeah it was pretty good eh um yeah it
was it was a
it was great life experience it was lots
of fun um
in the deep end a wee bit heading over
by myself at 21 to a place that i've
never even heard of but um it was cool
great experience
and what did you find about the quality
of rugby over there in the top 14. was
it top 14 or div 2 at the time
nah top 14. um
yeah it was good
um certainly a lot difference in new
zealand i'd say
the quality of training was certainly a
lot below par
so what i was used to here i remember
turning up my first day for bordeaux
um
that's training we're doing four corners
like gut walls and like popping in the
middle and then when we got really
expensive it was the old trucking
trailer
so i turned that was day one and i was
just going what the [ __ ] have i signed
up for here
but um nah the the boys could play
but the boys can play it was certainly a
different brand of rugby
um massively ford dominant
um and just size size means a lot loud
just have big number twelves running
down the channel all day
um
but uh it was yeah pretty good pretty
good standard like you're playing some
massive names over there yeah and how
did your debut go
um yeah debut was was good uh we're
playing um star francaise in paris so
uh
staff fronts had won the company year
before and i don't think bordeaux had
beaten them in paris in something like
10 years
so
we got to win i went all right did my
job um
and the president of the club president
of bordeaux was like
boys
outstanding work the night's on me he
said it in french but that was what
always translated it to me
so he
he pulled out his card and worked it on
some bar in france or in paris sorry
yeah so i was like a kid in a candy shop
i was on
over in france you know you you buy
bottles so you're buying a bottle of rum
or whatever and you're doing your solo
pause
and i was a wee bit heavy-handed that
night because
i've just blacked out and uh woken up
the next morning
and we had a bus
a bus to the airport at like 7 30 in the
morning or something
and i've been woken up by
uh my aussie teammate
there you go simon silent yeah i think
we must have busted off what time is it
it's 11 a.m
[ __ ]
so on my first away trip with the boys
i've missed the team bus missed the trip
back to bordeaux so i was just an
awesome it's like
i was [ __ ] myself like what are they
gonna do here but
we figure out we get our own way back
jump on a train
and uh
text the coach and he comes back and
he's like no worries you're allowed to
get away with that stuff and we have
good wins like that get back to water i
say so
so uh yeah no it was a pretty good
outcome in the end but yeah pretty funny
your first night out oh man that's
classic man they're so they're so um
results focused over there right like if
you're playing well everything's smooth
sailing eh like you said you can do what
you want pretty much but as soon as you
start losing that's when everything
turns
yeah hard out and i think part of that
is like promotion relegation yeah um you
know it's pretty stressful if you're
down in the you know bottom part of the
table you know there's always talk of
relegation or whatever um
yeah so the the ladder's going up in the
team meeting on a monday pretty much
every week um you're always aware of it
so yeah you did right huge huge results
focus and the other thing is like
massive
uh focus on winning your home games and
then you know what happens away is not
not a big deal
so how did the team go while you were
over there
we were decent day um
bordeaux
they've actually
gone really well in the last couple of
seasons but historically we've been like
a team that or we were a team that just
missed out on the playoffs so we were
finishing like seventh and eighth and
it's over there's top six so we never
quite made the playoffs but um yeah
we're always middle of the table at
least enough
so then why the move to edinburgh that's
another thing i've always wondered like
you were going so well in france you're
on massive coin and then you move over
to scotland
don't know about the massive coin um
but uh yeah it was
it was an interesting one um
i guess like three years living in
france by myself um
you know it can at times become a wee
bit isolating um
and so i was sort of during that whole
time i was looking at you know as a
opportunity for me to come home back to
that's new zealand or that super rugby
or whatever but it's always quite
difficult in terms of timing of
contracts because you're looking like
14 months ahead for the new zealand
super ugly team so it's quite hard to
get their interest um
so i was going going quite well for
bordeaux on my third season
um and then yeah i had a couple of
things
options pop up and one of them was
edinburgh
um
and yeah i'd say it was probably more my
decision was more on like
just my life as opposed to
my rugby at that stage so
um going up there was yeah it was
an exciting like going back to speaking
english and
experienced that uk culture so that was
a big part of it um
and
yeah yes i was just trying to ask the
way it worked out what were the other
options
um
stay at bordeaux or there's a couple
other clubs in france interested
in a lot of ways
enroll was a nice city
it was cold and dark but i knew it was
going to be cold and dark when i signed
to go and play for edinburgh so i
couldn't really complain about that um
we we actually did all right rugby wise
like we were sort of around the playoffs
we got a heineken cup semi-final
um which is
i think
uh
best
edinburgh had done it at that stage i
think so uh we weren't all right but
wouldn't play a great brand of footy to
be honest like she was pretty
nutritional um
drive
kept chase dominant that was the focus
so i didn't get many touches of the ball
so that that part of it was a bit
frustrating so was all that kicking from
nine
yeah all the kicking was from nine it
was which is i mean
it's happening a lot um around the world
but uh yeah a lot of clicking from nine
just contestables and then worry about
defense so how did your role change from
going from france what was your main
role in france and then what was your
main role in edinburgh
yeah france was a little bit more loose
um obviously they had their structures
and stuff but it was a wee bit more
just away as the frenchies say so
um you know had a bit more of a license
to throw it around
um whereas in edinburgh we went and we
were quite um
quite a tight team you know like
was more you know in new zealand that's
kind of around like decision execution
you know you might go for a cross kick
and
kick it out on the full but the decision
was good so don't worry about it just
nail the execution next time whereas
over in edinburgh it was more like
if you do something you better bloody
get it right otherwise it's not a good
decision it's only a good decision if
you execute so
um you're almost we're playing fair a
little bit which was um
tough for a new zealander
yeah and what other kiwis were there
with you at the time was you were you
there with the likes of hardy and stuff
nah i just missed the may so
um yeah john hardy and girls billy they
left the year before me
um unfortunately so i heard they were
good lads so it was just a um a guy
simon burgin who's played a few games
for scotland he's a kiwi but he uh
he didn't play footy in new zealand
really before before going over there
and apparently edinburgh nightlife goes
pretty good how'd you find that
yeah it goes pretty good um the scots
love today they have their socials and
they're pretty good fun uh
yeah so it was good the
nights of like test matches they were
effort
yeah they were good stuff and then
edinburgh also has a it's called the
fringe festival it's like pretty much a
month-long
party where the population doubles over
like july or august or something right
in the middle of pre-season so there's
plenty of um weekend activities then oh
man you would have been absolutely into
it
had my moments
so then why the move back to new zealand
and how did that opportunity come out
come up for you to return to the canes
yeah as i said um i sort of always
opened coming back home like and a lot
of that was just about
you know my life
outside of rugby you know i'm a big
family man and i miss them the whole
time overseas um
so i was always talking to my agent
about you know looking at how could i
get home ready right but it's hard to
you know it was hard to just sign for
like a minor team cup team
you know and you're leaving a decent
contract on the table
for
you know it's just taking a big risk so
um luckily i was back um
in january we had a couple of weeks off
when i came back and then
my agent said the hurricanes were
interested um so i actually flew down
whilst i was home and had a catch up
with alfie and
and co and um
then yeah like a couple of weeks later
they gave me an offer for
for the following year so
yeah i'll start day stokes come home i'm
really excited to play super rugby and
yeah it was i was first absolutely fizz
and how did how was your form for
edinburgh when you'd already signed your
next contract the following year did you
feel like that dropped at all or did you
feel like you're playing as well as ever
that was actually so covert i think i
signed from cairns in like january or
something like and then covert hit
in february or whatever so i i don't
even know if i played another game for
edinburgh after uh after signing for the
hurricanes
um
yeah it was a weird time weird time
so did you feel like you came back a bit
of player
from your overseas experience obviously
as a young fellow you were throwing in
the deep end you're playing starting
super rugby go overseas do you felt like
feel like you came back a bit of player
yeah i mean i felt like i feel like i've
come back with a far more um broad broad
mindset on ways to play the game like
growing up in new zealand um massively
biased on the way that we play the game
and
um you know throwing the ball around
play more expensive rugby
and particularly when you see the all
blacks winning like they did for or like
they have been um you know particularly
that huge dominant period where they won
the two world cups
you know you kind of go new zealand's
the best way whereas going over there
you know i learned that there are other
ways to play the game that might not be
as exciting but they can be
pretty effective as well so
um
yeah i think i've come back with uh
i guess just a bit more experience as
coaches of
summer um but um certainly like coming
back home it's been good to try and
sharpen up around my just my ball
playing and stuff where you get so much
more of that hedge a little
decision-making at the line and things
like that
nice and then i remember you coming into
the cane's environment always loved it
when a new
player would arrive to the squad
opportunity to try and get a prank call
and
mate i knew the pressure was on after
body had left everyone was looking for
this next big ten
jacko seemed to be coughing it from the
keyboard warriors so was fletcher so was
i so i'm trying to impress on you but
mate you handled yourself like an
absolute champion in that interview
that was yeah that was good from uae you
had me
absolutely hooked on today um i had no
idea
uh
yeah because yeah you just i don't know
whoever's listening has maybe heard that
one but just bagging out the other ten
pretending to be a radio host i was just
sitting there but what do i say
lucky i didn't incriminate myself that
would have been embarrassing
i probably could have tried a bit more
once we went off air and
[Laughter]
start really bagging the boys
yeah that would have been good stuff try
it down here see if i bag my fellow tins
down at the crusaders probably
it's probably a tough job matt not too
much bag
yeah is there many
many guys available for a prank down
there anyone you think would be
um able to get hotline and sinker down
there
uh i'll have a think i'm sure come up
with someone for you
one of the young boys
one of the gullible ones mate it's
getting harder and harder but
yeah it might be time to bring back a
good old-fashioned prank
but how did you find that um how did you
find the hurricane's environment
um
yeah it was good it was it was good fun
like i loved turning up to work each day
good
real good bunch of leads but
i still um keep in touch with a lot of
them
um real good real good lads it was
pretty relaxed environment
um you know but when they got on the
field they certainly worked hard
i was gathered i never got a game for
them um you know after getting injured
that that sucked so um
yeah sort of painted my experience with
it there but i mean as i said i love
turning up to work each day like good
lads so the following year after your
injury you'd obviously only signed the
one year contract was an offer from the
canes back on the table or was that was
that it done
no there wasn't another offer back on
the table
so i'd signed a one year i was off
contract
for this year um
and they were
saying there might be there might be
um an offer but um it just didn't work
out so um didn't have an opportunity to
go back there but stoked that uh you
know worked out to come down to
crusaders lucky they gave me
brazie gave me a lifeline
yeah good sir because you obviously had
a pretty disappointing
bunnings cut with auckland being pretty
much pulled out of the comp from covert
so what was that season to deal with
yeah it was weird
um
for me it was a bit different because i
wasn't going to be playing anywhere um
like i was i was not going to be playing
that season but i was living with
a bunch of the boys like sass and
scrap and
um a guy adrian cho from up at the blues
so i was living with them and i was just
like
in the waves you know like we couldn't
be playing this week could be playing
next week might be off to taupo tomorrow
not maybe off to tapo next week and then
eventually after like
six weeks of that or something it
finally got pulled pinned so
um i just felt real sorry for the young
boys like the
you know such a great competition for
particularly young boys to get a bit of
exposure and stuff
um and so to not get that was you know a
shame for them
and what was it like living with that
crew they sound like some absolute
roasters to live with was celesi still
doing his impressions every day or
what was scrappy like
jonty um
yeah
good crew to live with we had a bit of
funks we're locked down together um
so yeah we had a good time just taking
the mickey out of scrappy
um
yeah jonty wasn't fine for
the other person who would have been
gutted that that competition was um
auckland were pulled out of the comp was
roger two of us is sheik who was looking
to sort of give rugby his first crack
then
did you have much to do with him in that
environment or was it all sort of just
locked down you didn't really get to see
anyone
didn't get too much to do with him like
only in campbell for probably like three
weeks um i played with roger like at
school boys oh did you um so i knew i'm
a wee bit coming in um great seeing back
playing rugby again for auckland and the
blues it's f okay um
so i didn't see a huge amount of them
but um but there's no doubt that skill
sets there like you see him on the
training field and just some of the
stuff he's
capable of doing um is pretty incredible
and he's got a great work effort too so
you know little things like kicking and
um
you know passing under pressure on the
footy field uh you know i'm sure he'll
learn learn fast and just watch him
watching him play for the blues so far
to see them like you can tell he's got
the good
deadly footwork eh
yeah
and then so what's your plans going
forward you've got this year to see out
with the crusaders it's just the one
year deal isn't it so have you looked
any further ahead
yeah just one year deal with the
crusaders so um you know finish out this
evening here and hopefully get some
opportunities um you know there's still
a lot of footage to be played so hoping
that i can play a wee bit of that but
we'll just you know see what see what
time bring so it's going to be patient
um and uh then i'm heading back up to
auckland for the barning's comp which
would be should be good love playing for
auckland love that crew so i'm business
to get back up there and um yeah then
we'll go from there so i'm not so sure
what i'm up to you know from the end of
the year on but we'll just wait and see
and look forward to it it's a dream to
stay in new zealand now for as long as
possible or um depending on super gigs
yeah look i'm relatively open open to it
um you know like
if good opportunities pop up in new
zealand where
uh you know it looks like i'll be
getting the chance to
play decent minutes and serve rugby then
you know it's definitely i'd definitely
be keen to
um but then i'm also i'm not open to
going overseas again um
yeah just wait and see i've learned not
to look too far ahead gemma it's uh
yeah rugby's thrown some curveballs at
me over the last 10 years so just take
it day at a time almost right that is
that that is what you have to do but is
there any competitions that
um make you think man i'd love to give
that competition a go
um
i think i'll be keen to play in japan at
some stage eh um
yeah at the end but uh jono had a year
over there he loved it i've spoken to a
few people who have all enjoyed it um
enjoyed their time in japan so i reckon
i'll be pretty keen to give better
cracks lifestyles about um and play some
footy you know it looks like fast rugby
apparently the contact's not as big
which as a 82kg
um
rugby player these days isn't the worst
um
but mate i'm open i
play anywhere i love the french comp i'm
happy to ever play anyone get someone
must make river's best and your body's
feeling good feel like you've got plenty
of years left in you
yeah i reckon
i've got a few years left 28 now but
yeah um
body feels body feels good certainly up
to it um probably not as good as it did
when i was like 20 but
um certainly certainly for lots of uh
um requirements of of pro footy so mate
i've i've got no plans of stopping
playing anytime soon i um you know that
that can all change but yeah fingers
crossed i've still got a fair bit of
footy and and me i've been nice playing
to the mid 30s but we'll see
surely surely we see we see you plan to
your mid-30s so but we sort of talked
about it before um in that sort of seven
year time frame
i know you've spoken a little bit about
coaching not potentially the route
you're hoping to take but what is what
is the plans post footy what's what's
the dream for you
um
yeah i don't know i've actually
very proudly last year i finished my uh
10-year bcom
um yeah it took me 10 years to get there
but um
yeah so we'll wait and see um i'm open
to doing something away from rugby or um
or within you know we'll wait to see
business world um you know i'd be keen
to try something out in that at some
stage but um
you know
once time comes a little bit closer you
know just use those networks to try and
you know make sure that i'm ready for
whatever's next once rugby stops
so
how did you do your study was that just
a couple of papers every year yeah
pretty much um
yeah just chipped away part-time the
whole time occasionally i didn't do any
but um
i picked it up actually a bit more over
the last like two or three years i'd do
like you know
maybe four papers a year yeah and it was
good i honestly reckon i played better
rugby when i was studying and when i
wasn't
um
good good to give you something to take
your mind away from it because you're so
easy to ride the highs and lows of footy
um massively like you have a good day at
training or you have a bad day at
training you come home and you just you
ride that wave so it's nice to have
something to take my mind off of
particularly living overseas i had a lot
of time
with my own thoughts so um having
something else was great i think that's
something a lot of rugby players don't
quite realize is how much actual free
time you have as a professional rugby
player yeah you train hard when you're
training and
there are some big days especially
pre-season and the busy days of the week
but you've got a lot of time you've got
a lot of spare time that you can be
productive with and at the moment i know
a lot of guys don't really
um see much value in there and gaming
and a lot of things like that
occupy a lot of time punting for some
yeah
but there's an opportunity for
um to get really good at something and
like you say prepare yourself for life
after ugly i love that
yeah
hell it certainly doesn't have to be
study or whatever but i just think um
you know using sometime productively
like it just always made me feel a bit
better about myself you know like i
could be not select not selected on
tuesday and be gutted but then go home
and i've got
a couple of lectures to get through
which i don't necessarily enjoy but um
you know you get them done and then you
you feel good about yourself for it you
feel like you're getting away with
better so i think just finding some way
to use your time as you said we've got a
lot of what certainly
that's good for you
like that wow it leads into the next bit
my favorite part of the show every week
questions
and simon sickover
simon the sicko hickey has come up with
plenty in this one
um
heaps of questions from some of your lad
uh first question where is sickle from
this is from your good flatmate scrafton
um
where is sickle from uh well so back to
my club rugby days at grammar carlton um
there was a guy there called brickell
um he used to cop he used to cough a bit
of [ __ ]
um good man that used to used to cop a
wee bit of [ __ ] and um
and then uh
some of the boys
had started calling me sticky like simon
hickey and then that turned into into
sickle
and they made me do some weird stuff
so i think that's where
originated
yeah so i think that's where sickle
originated but then it sort of
progressed into other things like sick
little man and all this
oh good stuff okay next one are you
related to the weather guy jimmy hickey
uh
i think that dad might be like sticking
cousins with him or something not in
we're not related in any way that i've
ever met him good great man good weather
man
one of the great real good little man
yeah
is that a yarn second cousins of your
old man or
no like i think he might be a disappoint
today
he might be
good stuff okay now this is a question
that pretty much comes in every week all
the lads love a deuce story but what's
your favorite dude or what's your best
do story
um
or it's a toughy had a few had a few
good uh good trips but maybe um one
goodie was over
one of my good mates michael collins we
um we have both played in in europe our
first year over there and
before coming back to new zealand at the
end of the season we're like you'll
tie something good up see something good
up and
so we decided to go to greece for a week
um and just bounce around a couple of
party islands and
hell of a week and i ended up getting a
tattoo on my toe
and i sent my brother the photo but no
one else in my family
and uh
it was like a camel camel so and um
and mum caught one of it and or mom and
dad caught one of them and dad sent me
this message just cracking up like it
was hilarious and mum sent me this
message like just blowing me up she's
like i question your decision making
especially when you're on the piss no
more tattoos what the [ __ ] you doing
but it's faded a wee bit now can you see
that
oh yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's an easy laugh if anyone gets
offended by a little camel on your side
then i'm not too worried about being
mates with them anyway
oh classic okay the next one was it was
a yarn about um
your must be in your club rugby days
tell them about tell us about the
argument you had on the field with john
o'verse manukau
oh yeah this was quite good so um
i think jono was captain and
that he would just blow up referees like
these poor referees would just copper
and like by rifting everything club
footy like you're not going to get every
decision right but he would just blow up
at the ref and i just spent half the
game like trying to [ __ ] calm him
down i'm like mate it's not helping yeah
you blown up the wreath is not helping
and it's just turned into a full-blown
argument
on the field and so these people must
have just been like cracking up these
two little white guys
just having an argument nine to ten
years it was hard case
well what was it like playing club footy
with him you guys both sound like quite
angry man
um i'm not that angry i just used to be
angry
he's still angry
yeah so he's angry at rugby you're angry
at
yeah cricket playing playing card rugby
with jenna was yeah okay just playing
with him we played a bit with uh for
auckland too which was
which is great fun um the old 19 combo
but uh we just sort of
think very similar things so
um yeah we generally played pretty
pretty well together but club rugby
would just have like a kicking comp on a
friday and so he gets to kick goals on
saturday it was pretty yeah pretty good
fun yeah that leads to the next question
who is the better goal kicker out of
your bow
uh if you were to send us down to the
park now and have a kicking comment he'd
probably beat me but uh i like i like to
think that um games bring out my best
kicking
yeah when you were having your kicking
contest or how would you decide other
than whoever kicked the best
when we played for auckland i'd normally
kick the goals but yeah um
[ __ ] to be honest there's not much in it
he can kick it further than me
yeah i don't know is he still coaching
kicking
yep yeah he is
yeah he's good coach john i reckon he'll
be a footy coach one day he's good does
he coach your kicking
yeah we if i need some tips he's a
person i'll go too yeah oh how good is
that that was that yeah that was quite
funny growing up that would be he'd be
telling me to do something it still kind
of happens
it doesn't [ __ ] feel right it's not
going to feel right until you stop so
yeah
a little bickering but worked out pretty
well oh good stuff okay next one do you
still have aspirations to play test
footy
do i still have aspirations place yes
footy yeah i mean i can never say never
right um obviously as time wears on you
know it becomes less and less likely so
um
you know i'm
you know i'm not gonna come out here
about yeah absolutely hundred percent
want to be all black but
[ __ ] would love it
but it's gonna
take a couple of seasons of playing
regularly seriously good footy at super
ugly levels so you know as i said i
always take the day at a time and you
know whatever comes comes
okay next one what's big pablo like
good man hey yeah he's real good man um
i think
uh like when he was coming i sort of
expected quite a um like brash big
argentinian but he's like real gentle
gentle giant lovely man he's got time
for everyone um
yeah he's got a huge amount of respect
from the crusaders environment
yeah
because you watch him play especially
when he's playing for argentina you just
see this
physical big and looked angry a lot of
the time hey but yeah we haven't quite
seen that side of him um at the
crusaders he's obviously loving his time
down there
yeah yeah i think he is i think he's
loving it here um
i think it'll be good for rugby too you
know to play that a bit more of an
expansive brand but also with a bit more
detail like um coach is really pushing
his skill set and i think um like i
don't know how long he's stepping around
here for but you know when he goes back
and plays for argentina i think he'll be
a better player for his time with the
crusaders no doubt like that okay next
one next question is from our very great
sponsors swish swish question uh if you
could get a video shout out from anyone
in the world who would it be and why
uh
maybe tiger woods oh not tiger right
yeah i've got you're a pesky
i've got the golf bag big time so
um you know from target be quite nice
okay this was the most popular question
it came in maybe four or five times for
you and they're all around fire trucks
so what what's your all-time favorite
fire track
uh probably on my bedroom mate quite
much like
um
yeah no i used to
um sort of
you know once that first year out of
school came i really used to attack my
nights out with a fair bit of intent um
and uh that led to a couple of
situations where i had the
embarrassment of changing my sheets at
home on a sunday putting the mattress
out to dry
it's been
yeah
there's been a couple but i haven't done
that in years just so everyone knows
i've grown up i'm very mature now
i love it okay
uh who does next one who does it better
with the cordy scots frenchies or kiwis
uh
[Music]
kiwis i reckon although
it's also different now like the
frenchies are more likely to take you
out for a three-course meal and a few
wines and then
start to
uh you know start to drink properly at
like 2 a.m whereas
the scots and kiwi's more aligned than
going hard going early but uh
yeah i reckon you can't beat a good kiwi
cordial organization's always the top
drawer
yeah the buy-in is great although i
reckon quarters have gone downhill a wee
bit over the years i people weren't
buying as well as i used to
know like when when i was first year out
of school it was like you're a young boy
just shut up and do what you're told
yeah whereas now there's a lot of you
know a lot of chat coming from some of
the young boys
a little bit more difficult
no one's quite as easy push over as you
were
yeah
see what you're told it'll be fun i
promise
but look at yeah you had a lot of fun
yeah exactly
okay next one
uh play you most looked up to
um uh
it was a mix between like dan carter and
carlos um
i was like big blue supporter growing up
obviously from auckland so love carlos
that i was at that 2003 final that they
won that was pretty cool so loved carlos
but then
um dan carter he was the he was he's the
goat man so looked up to him and i
actually lucky enough to play against
him a few times though which is pretty
cool
how was that
yeah it was cool um
interesting like i played
i played him twice over in france
once here and um over in france like he
was a bit older so he probably didn't
have all the physical attributes they
had but just
he just pulled the strings um
yeah so well it was yeah it was pretty
cool to see firsthand
it's always cool when you're playing get
someone like that and you're just like
sort of an awe of them even though
you're supposed to be playing against
them
yeah yeah
that was yeah it was great
okay next question did he ever buy a
round in edinburgh
i'd love to know her ask that my my
guess is big
christine
um
[Music]
have you always been very um
have you always been good with your
money
um
like relatively i sort of um
you know like i was always
quite i'm keen to try and save up and
buy a house in auckland which takes a
fair
i've never taken rugby for granted in
terms of like
um oh it's gonna be here for the next
five years i've always been like well
i'm sweet for this contract but then
what if i get a career
or i'm playing terribly so i've never
taken it for granted so i've tried not
to blow it but
you know we'll prioritize
different things
that's it okay next one uh do you think
you could have gone far and qriket
um oh it's hard to say i don't know
crick is such a hard game um
i loved it and i was
yeah i was like massively passionate
about it all the way up until i stopped
playing but
i don't you know you can talk about it
all day but who knows like
it's a hard game cricket you might have
what it takes or might not like we'll
never know
yeah do you have you never played since
school then
i'm not properly a like i've played a
couple of games of last man stands which
is um
a bit of fun but never never like
serious cricket
takes too much time
they need to get you in that black clash
yeah we came for having the black clash
better be good stuff yeah you and johnny
yeah
yeah get john in there no that would be
good stuff opening the bedding
the lads
okay two more questions most memorable
moment on the rugby field
um
probably hard to get past my um super
rugby debut for blue zoe um
that was like an absolute uh dream come
true playing super rugby
and you know i'm at the crusaders now so
that's
where am i um you know where my heart
lies now but back then like playing for
the blues against crusaders um
you know we got the one that was yeah
that was a dream dream come true at the
time
nice okay last question and i know this
answer is going to be good because 10
years of traveling the world playing
footy everywhere some of the best
environments in the world
best piece of advice
simon hickey has for our waterload
listeners
whoa that's a tough one i should have
come prepared for this good good tell me
gamma i know you
well why don't we just go with what i
said earlier just um
you know all the
all the footy players just make sure
you've done something else alongside
your footing it'll help your footy and
it will help you help your life
off the field as well
i like that sometimes you need to say it
the second time to drum at home and that
was probably the perfect time to use
that technique you've you've used it at
the start and at the end just to really
reinforce how important it is what what
a great piece of advice
that's why i dropped it in slightly
earlier in the episode as
well oh mate you're an absolute lad it's
been a absolute pleasure to have you on
the podcast go through your journey only
28 years old feels like you've been
around forever captaining the blue
captain in auckland at 20 years old
incredible scenes
and mate it's been awesome following
your journey and it's awesome to get to
cross paths with you briefly um for half
a season there at the keynes you are one
of the great lads of the game and
looking forward to following you in the
future mate
beauty thanks for having me gemma um you
know likewise it's awesome awesome to be
on uh on the potty and i'm enjoying
following the wonderland journey mate so
i hope to see it keep growing and
growing cheers you're a champion
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
you